This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. You may know John Green as a YouTuber, a podcaster, or a mega-best-selling young adult novelist, but John's writing goes way beyond novels. His latest book is a nonfiction deep dive into one of the oldest and deadliest threats to humankind. You know, if you told me six years ago that my next book would be about tuberculosis, I would have been duly surprised. I did not think of tuberculosis as being really much of anything. I thought it was a disease of the past, like a disease that killed the guy in Red Dead
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。你可能知道约翰·格林是一位YouTuber、播客主，或是超级畅销的青少年小说家，但约翰的写作远不止于小说。他的最新著作是一部非虚构作品，深入探讨了人类历史上最古老、最致命的威胁之一。你知道，如果六年前你告诉我，我的下一本书会是关于结核病的，我一定会感到非常惊讶。我以前并没有把结核病当回事。我以为那是一种过去式的疾病，就像《荒野大镖客》里
Redemption 2, not a present-tense phenomenon. Tuberculosis is in fact the single most lethal infectious disease in the history of the world. It's been infecting and killing humans for millennia. But what makes the story of TB so maddening and what drew John to the topic is that the disease is still killing over a million people a year despite the fact that we already have a cure. John's book is called Everything is Tuberculosis. And in it, he describes how foreign policy
《救赎2》中杀死那个角色的疾病，而不是一种存在于当下的现象。事实上，结核病是世界历史上最致命的传染病。几千年来，它一直在感染并夺走人类的生命。但让结核病的故事如此令人抓狂，也是吸引约翰研究这一课题的原因在于，尽管我们已经有了治愈方法，但这种疾病每年仍在夺走超过一百万人的生命。约翰的书名为《一切皆是结核病》（Everything is Tuberculosis）。在书中，他描述了外交政策
and corporate greed make TB so hard to eliminate. He also explains the history of tuberculosis and all the unexpected and fascinating ways TB has shaped our world. I really love this book. It is both heartbreaking and triumphant. It is full of fun facts and sober realities. And I really just wanna have John on the show
和企业贪婪是如何让结核病变得如此难以根除的。他还解释了结核病的历史，以及它以各种意想不到且引人入胜的方式塑造了我们的世界。我真的很喜欢这本书。它既令人心碎又充满胜利感。它充满了有趣的知识点和严峻的现实。我真的只想请约翰来节目中
to talk about all the stuff he learned while writing it. So let's start at the very basics. I realized when I was reading this, I didn't have a full grasp of what tuberculosis actually was. So could you tell me about it as a sort of biological entity, what it does to you? How does it spread?
谈谈他在写作过程中学到的所有东西。那么，让我们从最基础的开始。我在阅读时意识到，我并没有完全理解结核病到底是什么。所以，你能从生物学实体的角度给我讲讲它吗？它对人体有什么影响？它是如何传播的？
Yeah, so it's a bacterial illness, but it's a weird bacteria. It's a bacteria with a really thick cell wall that takes a long time to make. And so relative to other bacteria, it grows very slowly. Like I think in a lab environment, it doubles every day, whereas something like E. coli will double every 20 minutes. So it's an unusual bacteria,
是的，它是一种细菌性疾病，但它是一种奇怪的细菌。它的细胞壁非常厚，形成过程很慢。因此，与其他细菌相比，它的生长速度非常缓慢。比如在实验室环境下，它每天分裂一次，而像大肠杆菌这样的细菌每20分钟就会分裂一次。所以它是一种不同寻常的细菌，
but it also that thick cell wall makes it hard for infection fighting cells to penetrate. And so usually what actually happens is that a bunch of white blood cells will surround some bacteria and kind of wall it off in what's called a tubercle, which is why we have the word tuberculosis. I think it's technically pronounced tubercle,
而且那层厚厚的细胞壁使得抗感染细胞很难穿透它。通常发生的情况是，一群白细胞会包围一些细菌，并将其封锁在所谓的“结节”（tubercle）中，这就是我们为什么称之为“结核病”（tuberculosis）的原因。我想技术上它的发音是“tubercle”，
but I don't like pronouncing it that way. It seems wrong. But this weirdness is one of the reasons why it's kind of both persisted and sort of inveigled its way into culture over thousands and thousands of years. And I'm really fascinated by this. And I'm also fascinated by the idea of like how it was,
但我不太喜欢那样发音。感觉不对。但这种怪异之处正是它在几千年来既能持续存在，又能以某种方式渗透进文化的原因之一。我对此非常着迷。我也对它是如何被……
but you know, before people knew of it as a bacteria, how it was conceptualized. Can you talk about some of the things that you found about how, you know, ancient civilizations treated this odd bacterium? Sure, so we've had tuberculosis or diseases very similar to it for all, probably all of human history and even further back in the story of people back to Homo erectus.
你知道，在人们知道它是细菌之前，它是如何被概念化的。你能谈谈你发现的关于古代文明是如何对待这种奇怪细菌的一些事情吗？当然，我们可能在整个人类历史，甚至更早追溯到直立人时期，就一直有结核病或非常相似的疾病。
And so we've had a long time to imagine tuberculosis and over the years we've imagined it lots of different ways. Some people saw it as a contagious illness from the beginning in ancient China and ancient India it was often seen as contagious. Some people saw it as an inherited illness, especially in Northern Europe and the United States. It was seen as a genetic disease that was associated with certain personality traits. If we go all the way back, we don't know that much about how we saw tuberculosis, but we know that it's probably Responsible for around one in seven of all human deaths of the hundred twenty billion people Who've ever lived about one in seven have died of TB and this is like by far the
所以我们有很长的时间来想象结核病，多年来我们以许多不同的方式想象它。有些人从一开始就认为它是一种传染病，在古代中国和印度，它通常被视为传染性的。有些人认为它是一种遗传性疾病，特别是在北欧和美国。它被视为一种与特定人格特质相关的遗传病。如果我们追溯到很久以前，我们对人们如何看待结核病知之甚少，但我们知道它可能导致了人类历史上七分之一的死亡。在曾经生活过的1200亿人中，大约有七分之一死于结核病，这绝对是
Championship killer of humans, correct? Yeah. Yeah, it's winning the all-time race In terms of infectious diseases, but it's also winning the current race, which is especially discouraging, because this year TB will be our deadliest infectious disease just as it has been for most of human history. Yeah. So tell me about that period of time where tuberculosis was actually called consumption, when it was perceived as a genetic malady,
人类历史上最致命的杀手，对吧？是的。是的，它是传染病史上长期的冠军，但它也是当前的冠军，这尤其令人沮丧，因为今年结核病仍将是我们最致命的传染病，就像它在人类历史的大部分时间里一样。是的。那么，请告诉我结核病被称为“肺痨”（consumption）的那段时期，当时它被视为一种遗传性疾病，
a poetic and romantic malady. Could you tell me about that? Because the real symptoms of tuberculosis, coughing up blood, extreme weight loss, A poetic and romantic melody. Could you tell me about that? Because the real symptoms of tuberculosis, coughing up blood, extreme weight loss, those don't sound beautiful or poetic. Yeah. So tuberculosis has always been a highly stigmatized disease, like any disease that's seen as very serious and threatening.
一种诗意而浪漫的疾病。你能跟我讲讲吗？因为结核病的真实症状，咳血、极度消瘦，那些听起来并不美丽或诗意。是的。所以结核病一直是一种被高度污名化的疾病，就像任何被视为非常严重和具有威胁性的疾病一样。
But at the height of what one person called the frightful tuberculation of humanity, at the height of the industrial revolution, tuberculosis was killing about a third of all people. It was killing rich people, poor people. Charles Dickens called it the disease that wealth never warded off. It was a disease that could strike anyone anywhere. And so we couldn't stigmatize it away.
但在有人所说的“人类可怕的结核化”高峰期，在工业革命的高峰期，结核病夺走了大约三分之一人的生命。它夺走了富人和穷人的生命。查尔斯·狄更斯称它为“财富无法抵御的疾病”。这是一种可以在任何地方袭击任何人的疾病。所以我们无法通过污名化来消除它。
We couldn't say, well, this is just a disease of the poor or just a disease of drunk people or just a disease of this marginalized group or that vulnerable group because it was a disease of everyone. And so for a period of about 150 years, especially in Northern Europe, it was also a hugely romanticized disease.
我们不能说，好吧，这只是穷人的疾病，或者只是醉汉的疾病，或者只是某个边缘群体或弱势群体的疾病，因为它属于所有人。因此，在大约150年的时间里，特别是在北欧，它也被极度浪漫化了。
And consumption was widely seen as an inherited disease. And it was a disease that made you literally more beautiful, made your skin pale and your cheeks rosy and your eyes wide. Like even as her sister was dying of tuberculosis, Charlotte Bronte wrote consumption, I am aware is a flattering malady. And it was also seen as a disease that made you into a genius.
“肺痨”被广泛视为一种遗传性疾病。这是一种让你在字面上变得更美丽的疾病，让你的皮肤苍白，脸颊红润，眼睛变大。就像夏洛蒂·勃朗特在她的姐妹因结核病去世时写道：“我知道，肺痨是一种讨人喜欢的疾病。”它也被视为一种能让你变成天才的疾病。
Like I remember Percy Shelley wrote John Keats when Keats was dying and said, well, you know, this consumption is a disease that tends to strike people who write good verses as you have done. You know, which was, which I find especially interesting because Shelley knew that he also had consumption So in some ways Shelley was like, you know, who else is good Okay, so in the US and Europe consumption made you this beautiful genius But then there was a shift from that thinking To seeing it as more of an infectious disease experienced by people who are not
就像我记得珀西·雪莱在约翰·济慈临终时写信给他说，你知道，这种肺痨是一种倾向于袭击那些像你一样写出好诗的人的疾病。你知道，我觉得这特别有趣，因为雪莱知道他自己也患有肺痨。所以在某种程度上，雪莱就像是说，你知道，还有谁是好样的？好吧，所以在美国和欧洲，肺痨让你成为这种美丽的“天才”，但随后人们的思维发生了转变，开始将其视为一种由非特权阶层经历的传染病，
privileged and that shift happens starting in the late 1800s when scientists discover that tuberculosis is actually a bacteria. Yeah, almost like a light switch. Very few things in history are like a light switch and I'm exaggerating when I say it's like a light switch. It was really like a decade, but that's relatively short. I often have people say to me, I wasn't aware that consumption and tuberculosis
而这种转变发生在19世纪末，当时科学家发现结核病实际上是一种细菌。是的，就像开关一样。历史上很少有事情像开关一样，我说它像开关是在夸张。实际上花了一十年时间，但这相对较短。我经常听到人们对我说，我不知道“肺痨”和“结核病”
were the same disease. And I tell them that totally makes sense because the way consumption was imagined culturally as this ennobling disease that made you beautiful, it made you sensitive, it made you write beautiful poetry is completely different from the way we imagine tuberculosis today. And those are all cultural constructs,
是同一种疾病。我告诉他们这完全说得通，因为“肺痨”在文化上被想象成一种能让你高尚、让你美丽、让你敏感、让你写出优美诗歌的疾病，这与我们今天想象结核病的方式完全不同。这些都是文化建构，
but of course that profoundly shapes not just how people live with the disease, but also who lives with it and who dies of it. And so once we understood that TB was infectious, we started to immediately or almost immediately see it as a disease of poverty, of crowded working and living conditions, of the cities that were called these, you know, these tubercular factories of urbanity or whatever.
但当然，这深刻地塑造了人们不仅是如何与这种疾病共存的，还有谁在与它共存，以及谁死于它。所以一旦我们明白结核病是传染性的，我们几乎立即开始将其视为一种贫困、拥挤的工作和生活条件、以及被称为“城市结核工厂”的城市的疾病。
Right. And so once people in the US and Europe figure out that TB is contagious, that leads to this sudden fixation on cleanliness. Can you tell us more about that? Oh, yeah, an obsession with hygiene. I mean, I think I republished in the book a poster that said, you know, do not kiss babies. Ha ha ha ha. Your kiss of affection brings the risk of infection.
对。所以一旦美国和欧洲的人们发现结核病是传染性的，这就导致了对清洁的突然痴迷。你能告诉我们更多关于这一点吗？哦，是的，对卫生的痴迷。我的意思是，我想我在书中重新刊登了一张海报，上面写着，你知道，不要亲吻婴儿。哈哈哈哈。你的亲吻带来了感染的风险。
And that was a big thing. Don't kiss babies, which is, you know, if you've ever had a baby, you just, you want to just gobble them up. But also, clean shaves became very popular because there was this so called revolt against the whisker as people believed that there must be untold number of bacteria crawling in those whiskers. Little did we know, of course, that half of all human cells are, in fact, microbial, and don't even belong to us. Okay, so this is kind of the part of the story, you know, when people have some purchase as
那是一件大事。不要亲吻婴儿，你知道，如果你曾经有过婴儿，你只想把他们吞掉。而且，刮胡子变得非常流行，因为当时有一种所谓的“反胡须运动”，人们认为那些胡须里一定爬满了无数的细菌。当然，我们当时并不知道，人体一半的细胞实际上是微生物，甚至不属于我们自己。好吧，所以这是故事的一部分，你知道，当人们对结核病的病因和传播方式有了一些了解时，我觉得你书中“一切皆是结核病”的部分就出现了。我们谈论的是19世纪末、20世纪初，我们开始看到这种疾病影响了建筑环境和设计。所以你能告诉我们一些“一切皆是结核病”的各种方式吗？是的，我的意思是，结核病塑造了历史，正如历史塑造了结核病。所以从阿迪朗达克椅（Adirondack chair）开始，它是为了让结核病患者能以特定的姿势坐着，以便他们表面上能吸入更多氧气而发明的，
to what causes TB and how it spreads, that I feel like the everything is tuberculosis part of your book, everything is tuberculosis comes about. We're talking the very late 1800s, early 1900s, and we start to see the disease influencing the built world and design. So can you tell me some of the various ways in which everything is tuberculosis? Yeah, I mean, tuberculosis shaped history just as history shapes tuberculosis. And so everything from the Adirondack chair, which was invented to give people living with TB a chance to sit at a very specific position so they could ostensibly get more oxygen into their lungs,
到新墨西哥州。新墨西哥州拥有建州所需的所有机构，并一直在寻求建州，但美国国会一次又一次地拒绝了他们，因为新墨西哥州有太多人不说英语，或者他们是原住民。坦率地说，由于种族主义，美国只是不想接纳这样一个州。所以新墨西哥州的人们就像是，伙计，如果我们想成为一个州，我们必须招募一些白人。
to the great state of New Mexico. New Mexico had all the institutions needed for statehood and was seeking statehood and the U.S. Congress turned them down again and again because so many people in New Mexico did not speak English as their first language or were indigenous people. And the US just didn't want to include a state like that, to be frank, because of racism. And so people in New Mexico were like, man, we gotta recruit some white people
他们这样做的方式是在城市里接触那些患有“肺痨”或结核病的人，并对他们说，嘿，来新墨西哥州吧，那里有广阔的天空、干净的空气、干燥的空气，你可以把那对潮湿的肺晾干。这奏效了，你知道，这是国会最终让步的一个重要原因，显然不是唯一原因，但这是国会最终让步的一个重要原因，
if we're gonna become a state. And the way they did that was by reaching out in cities to people who were living with consumption or tuberculosis and saying to them, hey, come to New Mexico, big skies, clean air, dry air, you can dry out those wet lungs of yours. And it worked, you know, it was a big part of the reason why, not the only reason obviously, but a big part of the reason why Congress finally relented
并将新墨西哥州纳入了联邦。到新墨西哥州真正成为一个州时，州内超过10%的人口是结核病患者。书中这一部分我最喜欢的内容之一是关于结核病和牛仔帽的故事。是的，牛仔帽肯定不会存在，或者至少不会像我们今天看到的那样存在，
and brought New Mexico into the union. And by the time New Mexico did become a state, over 10% of all people in the state were people living with tuberculosis. And one of my favorite things from this part of the book is the story about tuberculosis and cowboy hats. Yeah, cowboy hats definitely wouldn't exist, or at least not as we have them today,
因为约翰·B·斯泰森（John B. Stetson）是一位住在新泽西州的制帽匠，当他患上结核病并被告知去西部时，他去了西部并最终康复了。我们不知道为什么大约25%的人最终会从活动性疾病中康复并继续过上健康长寿的生活，但有些人确实做到了。我们从未理解这一点，至今仍不完全理解。但约翰·B·斯泰森是那些康复者之一，当他康复时，他想到的第一件事是，我想我可以改进这些帽子。这就是他发明斯泰森帽的原因。因为在此之前，西部的帽子是什么样的？
because John B. Stetson was a hat maker living in New Jersey when he got sick with tuberculosis and was told to go west and when he went west he eventually recovered. We don't know why about 25% of people will eventually recover from their active disease and go on to live long healthy lives, but some do. We've never understood that and still don't fully. But John B. Stetson was one of those who recovered and And when he recovered, the first thing he thought was, I think I can improve these hats. And that's how he came up with the Stetson hat. Because heretofore, what were hats like in the West?
所以他们在西部有浣熊皮帽，那上面简直全是虫子，对吧？简直恶心。然后他们有从墨西哥或德克萨斯生活的人那里带来的草帽，这很管用，除了下雨的时候，它们并不是特别防水。
So they had like, they had coonskin caps in the West, which were literally bug infested, right? Like disgusting. And then they had straw hats that were brought up from people who lived in Mexico or Texas, which worked great, except when it rained, when they weren't particularly waterproof.
所以约翰·B·斯泰森就像是，我可以轻松解决这个问题。我简直就是个制帽匠。我知道怎么做。好吧。所以你写的另一个与结核病相关的发明是疗养院，这是一种我们现在不再看到建造或使用的建筑类型，但在19世纪末是社会的重要组成部分。你能谈谈欧洲和美国的疗养院热潮吗？我的意思是，如今这些疗养院，我不知道你和它们的关系如何，
And so John B. Stetson was like, I can solve this problem easy. I'm literally a hat maker. I know how to do this. Okay. So another invention that you write about that's related to TB is the sanatorium, which is a type of building that we don't see built or used anymore, but was a huge part of society during the late 1800s. Can you talk about the sanatorium boom in Europe and the US? I mean, nowadays, these sanatoriums, I don't know if this is your relationship with them,
但它们主要是像城市探险空间一样。没错，是的。你知道吗？它们大多是位于奇怪地方的废弃建筑，27岁的人去那里寻找存在感。没错。但在疗养院热潮的高峰期，美国疗养院的病床数量几乎与所有医院的总和一样多。
but they're primarily like urban exploring spaces. Exactly, yeah. You know? Like, they're mostly sort of abandoned buildings in the middle of weird places that 27 year olds go to feel alive. That's right. But at the height of the sanatorium craze, there were almost as many hospital beds in the United States in sanitoria as there were in all hospitals combined.
这些巨大的建筑是结核病患者被送往或主动前往以试图恢复健康的地方。这些地方通常都在农村，或者像山区的空气是人们试图应对结核病的一种方式。干燥的空气是另一种方式，比如加利福尼亚州宣传自己是“新肺之地”，试图鼓励人们前往。
These huge buildings where people living with TB would be sent or would go in order to try to recover their health. These places were all often in rural places or in mountain air was one way that people tried to respond to TB. Dry air was another way, like California advertised itself as the land of new lungs to try to encourage people.
我想去加利福尼亚寻求结核病治疗的人数几乎和淘金热期间去加利福尼亚的人数一样多。所以这确实是一场大规模的人口流动。而他们在疗养院里所做的只是把人们隔离起来，让他们带着结核病休息。这并不是真正的治疗中心。不，那是一个休息中心。
I think almost as many people went to California seeking treatment for TB as went to California during the gold rush actually. So it was quite a movement of people all around. And all they're doing inside these sanatorium is just sequestering people to rest with their tuberculosis. It's not really a treatment center. No, it was a rest center.
所以他们称之为“治愈”，你每天必须“治愈”8到10个小时。当你“治愈”时，你通常会待在外面试图吸收阳光，但你不能动。在许多情况下，你不被鼓励说话。你不被鼓励有访客，因为那会刺激你的神经系统，这被认为会加重结核病。
So they would call it curing and you would have to cure for eight or 10 hours a day. And when you were curing, you'd often be outside trying to take in the sunshine, but you couldn't move. You were discouraged from talking in many cases. You were discouraged from having visitors because that could excite your nervous system, which was seen as a, as worsening TB.
所以那是一种高度、高度受控的生活。那么让我们谈谈结核病的治愈方法。人们是在什么时候弄清楚如何对抗它，而不是仅仅与它共存的？直到20世纪40年代第一种抗生素被合成出来，我们才有了治愈方法。这对结核病来说是一个转折点。我的意思是，当我的叔祖父在1930年死于结核病时，
And so it was a really highly, highly controlled life. So let's talk about the cure for tuberculosis. At what point did people figure out how to fight it rather than just live with it? We didn't have a cure until the 1940s when the first antibiotics were synthesized. And that was just a game changer for tuberculosis. I mean, when my great uncle died of TB in 1930,
他的名字叫斯托克斯·古德里奇，当他死于结核病时，真的什么也做不了。他们把他送进疗养院，他得到了金钱能买到的最好的护理，但他还是死了。这就是一遍又一遍发生的故事。但一旦我们开始在20世纪40年代开发抗生素，
his name was Stokes Goodrich, when he died of TB, there was just nothing that could be done. They put him in a sanatorium, he had the best care that money could buy and he died anyway. And that was the story over and over again. But once we started developing antibiotics in the 1940s,
然后到了20世纪50年代初，意识到我们可以将这些抗生素组合在一起作为一种“鸡尾酒疗法”，我们不仅可以治疗这种疾病并使其消退，我们还可以治愈它。在那一刻，你知道，成千上万住在疗养院的人突然能够回家，
and then eventually by the early 1950s, realized that we could use these antibiotics in concert with each other as a kind of cocktail, that we could not only treat the disease and have it retreat, but we could cure it. And in that moment, you know, hundreds of thousands of people who were living in sanatorium were suddenly able to go home,
过上他们的生活。那是一个彻底的奇迹，最高级别的科学奇迹。在1945年到1965年之间，我们开发了七八种不同类别的抗生素来对抗结核病。这是抗击这种疾病过程中极其成功的时期。
live their lives. It was an utter miracle, a scientific miracle of the highest order. And between 1945 and 1965, we developed seven or eight different classes of antibiotics that can fight TB. It was this hugely successful period in the fight against the disease.
在找到治愈方法的70年里，由于预防、广泛的结核病检测和强效抗生素的结合，结核病在西方国家已被有效消灭。但在整个全球南方，结核病不仅持续存在，而且还在蔓延。休息之后，我们将讨论一种有治愈方法的疾病如何仍然能夺走数百万人的生命，
In the 70 years since we found a cure, tuberculosis has been effectively wiped out in Western countries, thanks to a combination of prevention, widespread TB testing, and powerful antibiotics. But throughout the global South, not only has TB persisted, it is thriving. After the break, we'll talk about how a disease with a cure can still be killing millions
以及结核病的未来可能是什么样子。我们回到了约翰·格林的节目，谈论他的新书《一切皆是结核病：我们最致命感染的历史与持续存在》。所以你读到，尽管结核病长期以来一直致命且现在依然如此，但我们已经开发出了一些非常有效的预防结核病和从感染中幸存下来的方法。所以你能谈谈那个吗？所以不仅有药物本身的功能性进步，而且在分发这些东西的方式上也有进步。所以在我大学毕业后的25年里，结核病死亡人数下降了约50%。
of people, and what the future of TB might hold. We are back with John Green talking about his new book, Everything is Tuberculosis, the History and Persistence of Our Deadliest Infection. So you read about how even though TB has been deadly for so long and still is, we have developed some very effective ways for preventing TB and surviving the infection. So can you talk about that? So there's just the functional advance of the drugs themselves, but there's also advances in terms of how we distribute that stuff. So in the 25 years since I graduated from college, TB deaths have dropped by about 50%.
这很大程度上归功于投资，特别是美国政府的投资。美国政府长期以来一直是结核病研究以及整体结核病应对的主要资助者。此外，其他政府的介入也在从塞拉利昂到菲律宾等地方发挥了重要作用。所以这是大规模分发这些东西的关键。但我们在更早检测结核病以及提供预防性护理的能力方面也有其他重大创新。
And a lot of that's due to investment, especially by the US government. The US government has long been the leading funder of TB research and also TB response overall. Also, other governments stepping up have played an important role in places from Sierra Leone to the Philippines. So that's the key to distributing this stuff at scale. But there's also been other major innovations in terms of our ability to detect TB earlier, and then also to offer preventative care.
所以我们可以为接触过结核病的人提供一个较短疗程的抗生素，以确保他们永远不会生病。这可以成为阻断传播链的一种非常有效的方法。是的。结核病的另一个关键组成部分，因为它的生物学功能方式，
So we can offer a shorter course of antibiotics to somebody who's been exposed to TB to make sure they never get sick. And that can be a very effective way of stopping chains of transmission. Yeah. Another key component to tuberculosis, because the way it functions biologically,
检测几乎和治疗它的药物一样重要。你能谈谈检测在结核病方面的作用吗？是的，检测非常非常重要。它有助于更早地检测出疾病，因为这样你就不会有永久性的肺损伤。我们有这些很棒的工具，
is like detection is almost as important as the drugs to treat it. Can you talk about the role of detection when it comes to tuberculosis? Yeah, detection is super, super important. We've got a, it helps to detect the disease earlier because then you don't have permanent lung damage. And we have these wonderful tools
我们已经使用了很长时间，叫做胸部X光检查，你可以很快判断某人是否患有结核病。在过去的10到15年里，我们现在还开发了这些令人难以置信的分子测试，大约两个小时内就能告诉你某人是否患有结核病，以及他们的结核病对哪些抗生素有反应。
that we've had for a long time called chest X-rays where you can tell pretty quickly if someone has tuberculosis. We also have now over the last 10 or 15 years developed these incredible molecular tests that in about two hours can tell you not just if someone has TB, but which antibiotics their TB will respond to.
彻底的转折点。不幸的是，它们非常昂贵。我曾经在塞拉利昂的一个实验室里，我看到了他们的基因专家机器（GeneXpert machine），我说，哦，你们有基因专家机器。太酷了。他说，是的，如果我们能负担得起测试费用就好了。天哪。
Total game changers. Unfortunately, they're really expensive. I was in a lab once in Sierra Leone, and I saw their gene expert machine, and I said, oh, you have a gene expert machine. That's so cool. And he was like, yeah, if only we could afford the tests. Oh, my God.
好吧，我在读你的书时真正打动我的是，西方世界和世界其他地区之间存在着真正的对比。每年仍有125万人死于结核病，主要是在全球南方。这个数字对我来说太疯狂了，因为这是一种我们已经治愈的疾病。那么为什么结核病对世界上这么多地方来说仍然是一个问题？
Well, what really struck me when I was reading your book is that there's a real contrast between the West and the rest of the world. 1.25 million people still die of TB every year, mostly in the global South. And that number is insane to me because this is a disease that we cured. So why is TB still a problem for so much of the world?
对，这个问题涉及很多方面。结核病是一种可治愈的疾病，但并不容易治愈。当我们想到抗生素相关的细菌感染时，很多时候我们想到的是喉咙链球菌感染之类的情况，可以用7到10天的抗生素治疗。结核病需要至少四个月的每日抗生素，以非常特定的鸡尾酒方式服用，
Right, so there's a lot that goes into this question. TB is a curable disease, but it's not easy to cure. Like when we think about antibiotic related bacterial infections, a lot of times we're thinking about like a strep infection in our throats or that kind of thing, which can be treated with seven to 10 days of antibiotics. TB requires at least four months of daily antibiotics taken in a very specific cocktail,
通常是六个月，有时更长。而且它很繁重，因为我们仍然经常使用一种叫做“直接观察治疗”（directly observed therapy）的策略，你必须每天被一个非家庭成员的人看着服药。如果由于某种原因你无法去诊所，如果你病得太重，如果你负担不起交通费，无论是什么原因，那么你就无法获得药物，你可能会经历治疗中断。对。而且你确实谈到了你在塞拉利昂一家结核病医院遇到的一位病人，
often six months, sometimes longer. And it is onerous because we still often use a strategy called directly observed therapy where you have to be seen by someone who isn't in your family taking your medication each day. And if for some reason you couldn't get to the clinic, if you were too sick, if you couldn't afford transportation, whatever that is, then you wouldn't be able to access your medication and you could experience an interruption in treatment. Right. And you actually talk about one patient that you met at a TB hospital in Sierra Leone,
你深入探讨了他的故事，展示了获得良好治疗是多么昂贵和困难。所以跟我讲讲遇见亨利的事。是的。2019年，我和我的妻子莎拉与“健康伙伴”（Partners in Health）一起访问塞拉利昂，了解那里的孕产妇医疗保健系统，莎拉和我长期以来一直与PIH合作，与政府一起加强该系统。在我们旅行的最后一天，我们随行的几位医生问
and you get into how his story shows exactly how incredibly expensive and hard it can be to access good treatment. So tell me about meeting Henry. Yeah. So in 2019, my wife Sarah and I were visiting Sierra Leone with Partners in Health to learn about the maternal healthcare system there, which Sarah and I have been working on with PAH on strengthening with the government for a long time. And on the last day of our trip, a couple of the doctors we were traveling with asked
我们是否可以参观结核病医院。当我到达那里时，我打开车门，这个孩子就在那里。他直接抓住我的T恤，开始带着我在医院里走。我了解到他的名字叫亨利，那也是我儿子的名字。他看起来和我儿子差不多大。
if we could visit the TB hospital. And when I got there, I opened the car door and this kid was right there. And he just physically grabbed me by the t-shirt and started walking me around the hospital. And I learned that his name was Henry and that's also my son's name. And he looked about the same age as my son.
我立刻被这个孩子吸引了。他非常迷人且有魅力。他带我去了实验室。他带我去了病房。我被人们病得有多重而感到震惊。我以前从未，你知道，我在医院工作过，但我从未在一个地方见过那么多人病得那么重。
And I was immediately taken with this kid. He was so charming and charismatic. And he took me to the lab. He took me to the wards. I was astonished by how sick people were. I had never, you know, I've worked in hospitals and stuff but I'd never seen that many people that sick in one place before.
他带我去了做饭的厨房。然后最终我们回到了医生那里，他们把他赶走了。我说，那是谁的孩子？那是你们谁的孩子吗？他们说，不，那是我们非常担心的病人之一。事实证明，亨利并不像我儿子那样九岁。
And he took me to the kitchen where the food was made. And then eventually we made our way back to the doctors and they kind of shooed him away. And I said, whose kid is that? Is that one of y'all's kids? And they said, no, that's one of the patients we're really concerned about actually. And it turns out that Henry wasn't nine like my son was.
他17岁了。他的身体只是因为营养不良，然后因为结核病而发育迟缓。我的意思是，亨利可能在五六岁时第一次患上结核病，他开始接受治疗，但后来治疗中断了，这种情况有时会发生。
He was 17. His body had just been stunted by malnutrition and then by TB. And I mean, Henry probably first got sick when he was five or six with TB and he started to get treatment, but then that treatment was interrupted, which happens sometimes.
当这种情况发生时，你产生耐药性结核病的几率要高得多。这就是亨利发生的情况。他产生了一种对我们的一线抗生素有耐药性的结核病菌株。当我见到他时，他看起来身体状况良好，但医生们已经知道
And when that happens, you have a much higher chance of developing drug resistant TB. And that's what happened to Henry. He developed a strain of tuberculosis that was resistant to our first line antibiotics. And when I met him, he seemed to be in good health, but the doctors already knew
二线抗生素正在失效，他们成功地抑制了疾病，但现在疾病开始卷土重来。当那些二线抗生素失效时，这被称为注射方案。当那些注射剂失效时，你知道，有一位医生告诉我，那就是你放下听诊器的时候。真的没什么你能做的了。而且你知道，对于绝大多数像亨利这样的人来说，情况就是这样。
that the second line antibiotics were failing, that they'd succeeded in pushing back the disease, but now the disease was beginning to roar back. When those second line antibiotics fail, it was called the injectable regimens. When those injectables fail, you know, I had one doctor tell me that's when you put the stethoscope down. There's just not much you can do. And you know, that is the case for the vast majority of people who are like Henry.
是的，这真的很令人心碎。各国遇到的另一个障碍是高昂的护理成本。就像你谈到的基因专家结核病检测机器，检测一个人大约需要25美元。这超过了塞拉利昂每年人均医疗保健支出的一半。然后还有制药公司的贪婪，他们可以为救命药收取任何他们想要的费用。但你也说，针对这一点已经有一些成功的反击。
Yeah, it's really heartbreaking. One of the other obstacles that countries run into is the exorbitant cost of care. Like the gene expert TB testing machine that you talked about, which costs about $25 to test one person. That's more than half of what Sierra Leone spends on healthcare per person each year. And then there's the greed of the pharmaceutical companies, which can charge whatever they want to for life-saving drugs. But you also say that there's been some successful pushback against that.
是的。在1966年到2012年之间，我们没有开发出任何治疗结核病的新药，这真是一场灾难。但到了2012年，我们确实开发了一些新药，其中最重要的可能是贝达喹啉（bedaquiline），这是一种药物，其研究和试验主要由公共资金资助，主要是美国政府，
Yeah. So between 1966 and 2012, we didn't develop any new drugs to treat tuberculosis, which was a real catastrophe. But then in 2012, we did develop some new ones, the most important of which is probably bedaquilin, which is a drug that was, the research and trials for it were funded primarily by public money, primarily by the US government,
但专利实际上由制药公司强生公司（Johnson & Johnson）拥有。当他们的专利到期时，他们试图申请二级专利，不是针对药物本身，而是针对一种使药物更有效的化合物。印度的结核病活动人士非常聪明地诉诸法庭，并说，看，这不是真正的创新。
but the patent is actually owned by Johnson & Johnson, a pharmaceutical company. And when their patent expired, they tried to file a secondary patent, not on the drug itself, but on a compound that makes the drug more effective. And TB activists in India very smartly went to court and said, look, this is not real innovation.
这只是一家公司试图永远延长其专利。在他们因为这种化合物延长专利后，他们会找到另一种化合物来永远延长专利。在他们因为这种化合物延长专利后，他们会找到另一种化合物来延长专利。我们永远无法降低这种药物的价格。而价格是一个巨大的障碍。我的意思是，一个巨大、巨大的障碍。这就是人们死亡的原因，是因为价格。
This is just a company trying to extend its patent forever. And after they extend their patent because of this compound, they'll find another compound to extend its patent forever. And after they extend their patent because of this compound, they'll find another compound to extend the patent for. And we'll never get this drug's price down. And price is a huge barrier. I mean, a huge, huge barrier. This is why people are dying is because of price.
我的意思是，把药物送到需要的地方是一个挑战，但价格是最大的障碍。印度法院说，是的，这种化合物没有真正的创新。这只是试图让专利“常青化”（evergreen）。所以，在印度，获得仿制药贝达喹啉成为可能，但在世界上几乎所有其他地方，
I mean, getting the drugs where they need to be is a challenge, but price is the biggest barrier. And the Indian court was like, yeah, there's no real innovation in this compound. This is just an attempt to evergreen a patent. And so in India, it became possible to get generic bedaquiline, but in almost all of the world,
仍然有这些二级专利阻止仿制药生产。许多人联合起来，向强生公司施压，要求他们放弃二级专利，值得称赞的是，他们最终完全放弃了，所以现在贝达喹啉的价格在短短两年内下降了60%以上。所以我们现在正处于应对结核病的一个特别毁灭性的时刻。
there was still these secondary patents stopping generic production. And lots of people came together and pressured Johnson & Johnson to abandon their secondary patents, which to their credit, they eventually did completely so that now the price of binacolin in just two years has gone down by over 60%. So we're living in a particularly devastating moment right now for tackling TB.
自一月以来，特朗普政府削减了美国国际开发署（USAID）的资金，并将美国撤出了世界卫生组织。我们摧毁了资助结核病治疗的国际援助项目，而且药物研究也面临迫在眉睫的威胁。即使在美国，我们几乎消灭了结核病，但在过去几年里，病例也在上升。作为一名密切关注结核病历史的人，我很好奇这一刻对你来说意味着什么。
Since January, the Trump administration has cut USAID and pulled the US out of the World Health Organization. We've eviscerated international aid programs that funded treatment for tuberculosis, and there's also looming threats to drug research. And even here in the US, where we'd almost eliminated TB, we've been seeing cases rise in the last several years. And as someone who's been looking closely at the history of TB, I'm curious how this moment is landing for you.
是的，我的意思是，你知道，不是为了强调这一点，但我希望生活在一个无论最致命的传染病是什么，我们都知道如何治愈的世界里，对吧？因为至少那样的话，那是一个技术问题，而不是一个文化问题，不是人类建立的系统的失败，不是人类建立的系统的失败，
Yeah, I mean, you know, not to put too fine a point on it, but I would like to live in a world where whatever the deadliest infectious disease is, is one we don't know how to cure, right? Because at least then, at least then it's a technology problem, not a culture problem, not a failure of human-built systems, not a failure of human built systems,
不是榨取式资本主义的失败。只是我们还没有弄清楚某些事情。对于结核病，我们已经弄清楚了，我们知道该怎么做。我们以前做过。然后几乎同时，看着我们背弃这些进展，这绝对是毁灭性的。而且不仅仅是，你知道，真正的问题在于你不仅仅是背弃进展，你是在拥抱倒退。
not a failure of extractive capitalism. It's just that we don't have something figured out yet. With TB, we have it figured out, we know what to do. We've done it before. And then almost all at once, there's been this absolute devastation of watching us walk away from that progress. And not just, you know, the real problem is that you don't just walk away from progress, you embrace regression.
这就是我们现在正在做的。我们正在拥抱一个变得更糟的世界。你认为这些削减对世界上患有结核病的人有什么影响？这简直是毁灭性的。我的意思是，我们将看到死于结核病的人数上升。现在每一个治疗中断的人，我们甚至不知道那是多少人，
That's what we're doing right now. We're embracing an actively worse world. And how do you see these cuts hitting people in the world with TB? It's just devastating. I mean, we're gonna see the number of people who die from TB go up. Every single person right now who's had their treatment interrupted, and we don't even know how many people that is,
但那是成千上万，几十万人。每一个这样的人，即使他们在未来几周内重新开始服药，在许多情况下，这种药物很可能不再起作用了，因为细菌将有机会进化出耐药性。而且以如此混乱、如此突然的方式，没有任何警告，全面地，用斧头而不是手术刀来做这件事，我不知道如何表达我感到的毁灭感。我的意思是，我不感到绝望。我不知道如何表达我感到的毁灭感。我的意思是，我不感到绝望。
but it's tens of thousands, hundreds of thousands. Every single one of those people, even if they get back on medication in the next few weeks, it's likely that in many of those cases that medication won't work anymore because the bacteria will have had an opportunity to evolve resistance. And to have done that so chaotically, so suddenly, without any warning, across the board, with an axe rather than a scalpel, I don't know how to express the devastation I feel. I mean, I don't feel hopeless. I don't know how to express the devastation I feel. I mean, I don't feel hopeless.
我不感到绝望。我拒绝感到绝望，但已经很久没有像现在这样沮丧了。你看到的具体发生了什么，比如什么被关闭和改变了，什么样的协议被修改了？是什么导致了这种倒退？所以几乎立即就发布了停工令，
I don't feel despair. I refuse to feel hopeless, but it's been a long time since I was this discouraged. What are some of the things that have happened specifically that you've seen sort of like what has been shut and changed, what sort of protocols have been altered? What is it that is causing this regression? So almost immediately there were stop work orders issued
涉及几乎所有的结核病应对、艾滋病应对、疟疾应对。但传言说救命药物有例外。每个人都被告知了这一点。现在，实际上，据我所知，我在这个领域有很多朋友，我和很多人一起工作，
related to almost all TB response, HIV response, malaria response. But the word was that there were exceptions for life-saving medication. That's what everyone was told. Now, functionally, as far as I could tell, and I have a lot of friends in this space and I work with a lot of people,
实际上几乎没有资金在流动，如果有的话。所以你可以说救命药物正在流动，但事实并非如此。相反，你知道，我会收到朋友发来的仓库里堆满结核病药物的照片，仅仅因为缺乏持续的工单而在仓库里腐烂。然后最近，所有或几乎所有的结核病应对措施都被完全削减了，只是
very little money was actually moving, if any. And so you can say that life saving medication is flowing, but it wasn't. Instead, you know, I would get pictures from friends of warehouses full of TB medication, just rotting in the warehouse for want of a continued work order. And then more recently, all or almost all TB response was just cut completely, just
结束了。疟疾应对措施也是如此，我们很大一部分艾滋病应对措施也是如此。这简直是毁灭性的。会有这么多人死去。就像你一样，我对这一刻感到非常沮丧。允许这种事情发生感觉就像是一种难以想象的残忍。我不想让你处于必须给我们提供希望的境地。但你能分享一下你的感受吗？
ended. And that's the case for malaria response as well for a huge percentage of our HIV response. And it's just devastating. So many people are going to die. Just like you, I am incredibly discouraged by this moment. It feels like an unimaginable amount of cruelty to allow this stuff to happen. And I don't want to put you in a position where you have to provide us with hope. But could you share anything that you're feeling
关于可以做什么，什么能让我们走上正确的道路？是的，我的意思是，作为一个人，你的本质就是觉得今天就是人类历史的最后一天，对吧？因为这是你经历过的人类历史的最后一天。感觉就像故事的结局。
in terms of what could be done, what would put us on the right path? Yeah, I mean, the nature of being a person is that you feel like today is the last day of human history, right? Because it's the last day of human history you've lived through. It feels like the end of the story.
就像有一个，你知道，我从零开始，然后我到了47岁。这就是我的人生故事，对吧？但当然，那不是我的人生故事，希望如此。希望这不是最后一天。这不是故事的结局。感觉像是故事的结局，因为这是我经历过的最后一点，但这是故事的中段。所以这就是为什么我们必须战斗、挣扎并继续保持希望，因为这是故事的中段。所以这就是为什么我们必须战斗、挣扎
Like there was a, you know, I started out zero and then I ended up 47. And that's the story of my life, right? But of course, that's not the story of my life, hopefully. Hopefully this isn't the last day. This is not the end of the story. It feels like the end of the story because it's the last bit I've lived through, but it's the middle of the story. And so that's why we have to fight and scrap and continue to be hopeful because it's the middle of the story. And so that's why we have to fight and scrap
并继续保持希望，因为这是故事的中段。我真的相信结核病故事的结局就是结核病的终结，这种在我们存在的所有30万年里一直伴随着我们的疾病。如果能生活在一个不再是公共卫生威胁的世界里，那该有多棒？好吧，我们可以生活在那个世界里。而现在我们正在远离那个世界，但那些并不是我们永远要走的最后一步。约翰，和你谈话非常愉快。我真的很喜欢，而且我非常喜欢这本书。谢谢你邀请我。谢谢你愿意读这本书，
and continue to be hopeful, because it's the middle of the story. And I really believe that the end of the story for tuberculosis is the end of tuberculosis, this disease that has been with us for the whole 300,000 years that we've been here. How amazing would it be to be able to live in a world where that's no longer a public health threat? Well, we can live in that world. And right now we're taking steps away from living in that world, but those aren't the last steps we're ever going to take. John, I've had such a great time talking with you. I really loved it, and I love the book so much. Thank you for having me. Thank you for offering to read the book,
以及在这个世界上成为一个如此善良的灵魂。本周的《99% Invisible》由克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作，凯利·普莱姆编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德创作。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·莱、拉什玛·道恩、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森。
and for just being such a kind soul in the world right now. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Christopher Johnson and edited by Kelly Prime, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lay, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason,
感谢你在这个世界上展现出的善良。本周的《99% Invisible》由克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作，凯利·普莱姆编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德配乐。凯西·图担任执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德担任数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔担任高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·雷、拉什玛·道恩、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森。
and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora Building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky, as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that,
还有我，Roman Mars。99% Invisible 的标志是由 Stefan Lawrence 设计的。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员，总部现位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区，就在北边六个街区外的潘多拉大厦。你可以在 Blue Sky 上找到我们，也可以加入我们的 Discord 服务器。那里有一个链接，
as well as every past episode of 99PI, including one where I talked to John Green about his book and podcast, The Anthropocene Reviewed, which is actually one of my favorite episodes. You will find it at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目，包括我与 John Green 谈论他的书和播客《人类世综述》(The Anthropocene Reviewed) 的那一期，那实际上是我最喜欢的节目之一。你可以在 99pi.org 上找到它。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。